man was this fun over the weekend it's
been a fun series in the stands so
freddie freeman homered on friday
philly fan had it in his glove dropped
it and then he got the ball thrown to
him he dropped it again and his dad
his dad's beside himself
the young man got the ball and then he
flipped it to a younger braves fan
really such a great gesture such a sweet
moment so what happens tonight freddie
freeman is told of what went down
signed a ball for that young man the
ball had also been signed by bryce
harper so that young man with one act of
generosity had it paid back to him and
then something and braves go with the
left-hander drew smiley tonight juice
miley's going a bit harder he's got a
fastball you see it up to 95 today both
sides of the plate he's got to cut her
into the righties and away from the
lefties he's got a change up and his
signature pitch is the curveball and
you'll see a bucket of them tonight he's
facing mccutcheon hoskins and harbor
this is a high pop
in the infield
austin reilly giving way to dansby
swanson and there's one god and maddie
with both left-handed pitchers today
there's a lot of right-handed hitters
here's rhys hoskins offering
aggressively
a notorious count worker is a one-pitch
casualty in his first try tonight for
drew smiley by the way as harper digs in
with two guns he's looking for his first
win since he wore a philly's uniform
back in 2019. oh two on the way swung on
and missed strikes out harper with a
curveball
and smiley dices right through the
phillies in the top of the first inning
ronda lacuna junior leads things off
against the veterans southpaw matt moore
31 years old pitching for his fifth
major league team in this his 10th big
league campaign
spent last year in japan he's underway
tonight on the road a first pitch swing
by acuna
hustling all the way that's a routine
ground ball to short that acuna somehow
beats out i mean that's hard to believe
some players run hard some run fast this
is both right here that's even more
impressive than the home run because it
gets everybody going in the right
direction
and the first pitch to ozzy albies is
sent out to right field and gone
just his second plate appearance of the
year from the right side
and it's taken two pitches to put the
braves on top two nothing perfect
example how you want to start the game
two pitches
gromball small ball long ball
star no steps in travis who's hit safely
in each of the first two games of the
series and darno serves that into the
opposite field that'll roll all the way
to the wall
a little bit everything in this first
inning against matt moore throughout
double puts a runner in scoring position
dansby swanson also off to a a slower
start by his own standards the next
one-two to swanson
lined up the middle of base hit
quinn throwing to the plate it's not in
time as darno scores it's three-nothing
atlanta
go to
20 minutes for three runs of support as
real muto sends one whizzing past riley
on into left field jt on his way into
second
with a lead off double got a big zone
like texas there he goes jt runs
throw down from darno not in time and i
like this play here by rio muto i mean
aggressive lead off double
they're down 3-0 but they still want to
play aggressive so now gene segura
digging in is the sixth batter that
smiley has faced segura sends a fly ball
out to center field that one's carrying
for pache who makes the catch at the
wall more than enough to tag and score
real muto and the phillies get one of
them back immediately here in the second
billy cut the lead 3-1
3-1 to mccutcheon a shot to third riley
gobbles it up and gets it there in
plenty of time what a play life of riley
tonight
dirty and effective three to one razor
leading in the fourth drew smiley winds
up in the three-two pitcher hoskins
there's a long drive to left by hoskins
and he has tied it
or rather pulled it to within a one-run
game solo shot for rhys hoskins is his
second of the year three to two atlanta
this is a fastball way that he yanks to
left center field
reaches out there with the barrel and
brings it nice home run right there
first and second now for dede gregorius
trying to convert on the modest
eight-game hitting streak that he's
opened the season with one two
to right field and well hit and on cue
it's gone
sir dede pulls another and it was a
curveball that did not curve it never
got there he wanted it low away it came
in the happy zone
and oh my sir dede with a three run
homer to a one run game with a fly ball
off the bat of rhonda lacuna junior who
has been hot tonight and all weekend
long
come back in there and acuna slugs it
out to right field
should be more than enough to plate
pache
and it is a one-run game
bottom half of ending number five in a
one-run game middle of the order in
freeman we're here in the fifth
freddy making a bid to score
and that one gets out of here
he's homered in three straight the
reigning mvp is heating up five hits for
freddie freeman this year four of them
have been homers so smiley removed for
the veteran right-hander nate jones
making his fourth appearance as a brave
had a very good spring spent his entire
career with the white sox until becoming
a little more well traveled the last
season here's bryce harper to lead it
off against jones in the sixth ball in a
strike to count to harper who has struck
out twice tonight that's well hit into
the opposite field and bryce got him
third homer in the last inning plus for
the phillies
and the visitors go back out on top that
ball came in mid 90s and i got out 112
miles an hour laser a line drive over
the shore stops ahead for a home run
hard throwing ex san francisco giant
gets ahead of rhonda lacuna junior
first is swing by albie's in a drive
rather by acuna and a drive to center
that's going to go
ronald lacuna jr has done it again oh he
was ready for the velo that time i mean
we're watching something so special here
108 miles an hour
i did not like the pitch it was a little
cutter at 90 miles an hour just sped up
the bat of acuna he knew it when he hit
it the twist the turn
a little merengue salsa
bomb with a shot out to right center
field well hit and it's off the base of
the wall
[Applause]
alec boom into second representing the
go ahead run with nobody out in the
night here's gene segura now
swinging away it's going to work as a
bunt however that'll move the runner
into third base with less than two out
and the phillies have a chance to grab
the lead with a well-placed fly ball
deedy pops that one into the opposite
field
ozuna's got it boom's gonna try it here
he comes and he's safe in the plate
wow
on a
shallow fly ball into left field they
roll the dice with ozuna's arm
and boom is able to score on a bang bang
play at the plate
lined up the middle and gathered in by
gregorius and the phillies hang on for a
series salvaging victory in game three
with the braves
did not come without some controversy